greetings and peace welcome to the dean
shaw mr your host now i want you to
imagine this
how many times have you had to guess do
you think a muslim minding his or her
own business via be at work school on
the street
has been called some derogatory name
concentrated on my prayer and you know
this is the specific time between me and
god started to recognize what this woman
was saying she was telling me that i was
an effing terrorist how even children go
into public school with the name ahmed
mohammed fatima have been called
terrorists every muslim is a terrorist
period right now
i don't want to hear your mouth even
though it's a statistical fact that
muslims do not commit most acts of
terrorism it's not because muslims are a
bigger threat
in fact between 1980 and 2005
94 percent of all the attempted or
successful terrorist attacks on u s soil
were not
carried out by islamic radicals but
instead by non-muslims mostly white guys
so then why the obsession
is killing of innocent human beings
human life is precious in this country
do they blow people up against yes
christians every day people walk in the
post office i mean
people walk into post offices they walk
into schools that's what columbine i
mean i can do this all day long there's
so there's so many more examples of
christians and i happen to be a
christian that's back to this notion of
your idealizing christianity in my mind
to my read there's so many more examples
of john of christians who do that then
you could ever give me examples of
muslims who have done that inside this
country where you live and work it's a
statistical fact that muslims do not
commit most acts of terrorists
domestically or globally it's objective
research data
they don't
now my next guest actually had this
happen to him
he went he was went to work
and an israeli man ends up calling him a
terrorist why
only because he's a muslim let's bring
out our next guest
javed ahmed
salam alaykum brother
is that what happened
that's exactly what happened
he's not going to have an easy way out
at the same time guys you don't need to
stoop to his level
and
especially as a muslim
you know
we advise not to do this either you know
show the people that this is a religion
of uh
peace
and
he's the only one that looks bad here
was that something uh
just totally unexpected
to be honest it was it was very
unexpected like the the the comment in
general like i've been called that
before like you like you said in your
intro and whatnot you know like growing
up in in england and stuff
but
in terms of uh hearing it from him
especially when the cameras are on
you know people this is a politically
correct world right now so
people
even they even if they have a feeling
like that they tend to not say it so
when he said it in public like that with
cameras and people watching
it was very shocking to me to be honest
now i just want you to imagine what if
it was the roles were flipped because
there's a obviously i mean you know you
just you actually had this happen to you
before you've been called this there
you're originally you're from london
yeah yeah so you know growing up just
generally like
especially after that whole 9 11 and
whatever brand new poll that show that
more and more americans are rethinking
what happened on 9 11 and increasingly
more people are saying they do not
believe the government's version of
events like i was a young kid when all
of that happened so every time there was
like some sort of
news about muslims
you would get called out on the street
like it's normal you know
now
you
actually got to do something a little
bit different i mean it's not everybody
now gets to
you know be in a situation like you
this happens and then you end up locked
in the cage together
and then he can't get out now so you
legally you had uh
a way to express yourself right yeah so
what happened from there
so
yeah exactly exactly so this is why
the the i can't take full credit for me
reacting the way i did
you know um now in hindsight when i look
back i'm glad that i didn't react like
that uh you know and it didn't make me
look bad like by by doing something
silly like hitting him or swearing back
at him or whatever you know your
composure very well yeah
yeah exactly but partly was because i
knew i'd get my time with him
you know so uh and i had to make him
suffer for his for his words
and that's what happened you know
there's a lot of double standard there's
obviously we know that like you know
you're praying like oh please like if
something does happen and some lunatic
goes and does something we're like oh
please don't let him be any way which
way uh connected to islam right and the
media usually if it's some person with
mental health issues he's just like you
know crazy whatever the case some fringe
element and the media runs with it
double standards how about you know a
lot of people are pointing out now
like if this was it was flipped if
you end up calling him a terrorist for a
lot of the terrorizing that a particular
group of people are doing against
palestinians kids and whatnot we know
what's going on for anyone just
objectively looks at it and now if you
just came out and called him a terrorist
uh what do you think would have happened
no it would have been it would have been
crazy like i i think i would have got
the well uh
i would have got it a lot worse than he
did to be honest
you know but
i don't feel like i should be dwelling
on that and like watch what could have
happened and what would have happened i
feel like
it says allah
allah
children of israel in arabic language
and it's the god for the arabs who are
christians it's also the same god for
the muslims the word is allah has a way
of
of uh there's a word that allah uses uh
often in the quran for these type of
people and it's like and it says allah
will humiliate them
you know it's a very particular word and
it and it hits home with me because that
was a and he eventually did get
humiliated and i'm glad that people
um
saw it and i'm glad that people
reacted the way they did
you know uh and
i did get a lot of support for it and it
shows and it's not just from muslims
from all over the world you know so it
is good that there are good people
especially in the sport that they they
don't i really don't like to tolerate
this but at the same time yeah if i had
said something like that it would have
been crazy yeah and it was god of uh you
had some headlines on it but obviously
it didn't i'm thinking you know flip the
other way around probably mainstream
media you know even at a bigger level
picking it up all over the case
you know uh they don't let that kind of
stuff go you know it's it would have
been term anti-semitic et cetera et
cetera and it would have just been out
of control
so it's just uh these double standards
but it's i like what you said you know
um this is very important and you kept
your composure you kept it cool but you
know it just gave for many people who
uh have been have gone through this you
know what i mean and education is so
important that's how we do the dean show
educating people so they can have a
better understanding because most people
are just you know misled by hate by that
you know negative propaganda a lot of
the um hate machine that's out there but
you you had a good opportunity now to
hold your composure and uh at the end
there was some justice sir
exactly there was justice uh um yeah but
i feel like as a muslim
especially
like you said there's a lot of double
standards right now you know um i had
when when it all happened i knew i had a
responsibility to to keep my call and
keep keep it calm especially not saying
anything racist back not that i was even
thinking of doing it anyways because
i'm not racist you know what i mean but
at the same time i had to make sure that
i showed the etiquette of islam you know
and how
we should deal with situations like this
and then justice was served i knew i'd
get my time with him and that was nice
you had a message at the end what was
that message you put out a message
talking about how we should conduct
ourselves that was a real nice positive
message yeah well what people don't
understand is islam
is literally a religion of peace
you know so when somebody calls you
something or when somebody i'm not
saying i'm the best example by any means
but i knew it in this time this was my
moment to to show my character and allah
was testing me to to
to not not say anything back to him or
and make sure
not that i would but make sure i know
people on social media and stuff would
start making this like a
like islam versus
israel sort of thing you know
i had to make sure like don't
make sure you don't make any racist
comments this guy is the problem not not
his people but his people didn't really
say anything you know
um
he doesn't represent the whole country
i'm sure that we all know what israel
are doing and and stuff with palestine
and their war going on and but that's
different that doesn't represent every
israeli person you know so especially
being racist to a religion or or a
culture in particular
uh it shouldn't happen yeah absolutely
not but you you can imagine like what is
and that's the if we can reach people
you know because
you know
people get programmed people see other
people and then you know these things
need to be put in check right uh
socially you know culturally that it's
not acceptable uh because
you're at a grand scale like this a
sport where people accept each other
different religions different
nationalities etc and you got to just
think like really what's going on inside
of a human's head in their heart you
know to just come out and just you know
what kind of venomous hate that that
person has that they they want to just
go to such a low low level you know to
you know give you such a low blow you
know that's that's
you know
well that's that that's the sad part you
know that is exactly what he said that
the hate in these some of these people's
heart you know it's it's quite shocking
and it makes me kind of like think like
panda well i grew up in london so like
alhamdulillah like i had a lot of um
people from all over the world that i
would go to school with i see on the
road and whatever like yeah you'll get
racist comments by the end of the day
there is a community in the sense like
uh there are people from all all part of
the world and people get along so for
for people
so it's just crazy and mind-blowing for
me to
to
even think like why people
can be racist and and have that venom
and hate that you spoke about in their
heart
you know
tell me at what what age did you start
turning were your fat was your was your
family were you always someone who was
practicing your dean you know uh were
you somebody who was also like you know
because you have a lot of people who now
because explicitly because of this you
know muhammad changes nate to moe
you know fatima they're they're scared
people don't have the courage there a
lot of times they run away from their
deen because you know of such things
they they fear things like this uh being
put under the spotlight and whatnot how
did you get so connected with islam with
your with your deen alhamdulillah
i always have to credit my parents for
this i always i even get emotional
thinking about it because
um i i don't know where i'll be without
without them and without them showing me
the value of islam you know especially
growing up like it's not cool to be a
muslim like i don't know
if i said that correctly but
there's there's rules and and stuff that
you have to follow and if you if you
don't understand why you're following
these rules and and why you're muslim
it can be hard it could be hard for you
to get along with people in a society
where the religion is not
the dominant
way islam is not the dominant religion
you know and they put me in like
a koran school quran school and
they they taught me the way and the
etiquette
and
at the end of the day they instilled the
mindset in me that
without this dean
i i'm just i'm not
i won't be complete without this dean
you know
and and many uh many people don't know
simply when you're saying islam you're
you're saying that that submission to
the creator you know trying to achieve
peace by submitting to the owner piece
the one who created creation and many
people don't know when you start
educating people our deep love and
reverence for jesus peace be upon him
moses and all these messengers who came
with the same way of life that you're
living and you're proud to be upon
worshiping the creator not the creation
and that's why education is so so
important because uh people have all
these misconceptions misnotions
and uh when they actually connect
with a muslim go to a mosque you know
ask the questions because a muslim is
just like you he's trying to live in
peace he's trying to live in harmony
with his creator and with the creation
around him
and this is what you're trying to do so
this is it was really nice uh
to uh uh connect with you and you know
bring this story to light this is very
this is i think very important for those
who are hopefully this can
um
deter someone else
from doing something making this mistake
that was that happened to you towards
you
yeah exactly exactly you know then the
day it's just about you we have to
understand that
you represent islam you know we this is
what my parents made clear to me also
when i was younger like
people are not going to know
you can't educate everybody the way the
way they know is through your actions
tell me uh you so you're in in vegas now
yes yes i'm in las vegas so
you're uh
with uh jake shields
yes i'm with jake shields and uh my
teammates fired and admiral bazi okay
yeah i've met jake shield he's actually
visited uh my academy so he knows uh we
know each other
and uh
how's he doing
nice i'll be speaking about you with him
later um yeah he's he's great jake is
what a guy
what a guy you know such a chilled back
guy and open-minded and he's just an
overall good guy man and he was
he was telling me as well before the
fight like like i know that you're not
gonna do it anyways but just make sure
you don't make any comments and and stay
true to your character and and this is
important because
uh
yeah you have to be true to your
character you know yeah he's a veteran
giving you some some good advice yeah
exactly uh how about uh he's uh best
friends with uh tara kazeem have you met
tatak yet yeah
i love you cut out a little bit what'd
you say you cut out
it was actually the
day
he what
sorry this is
we're look we lost you there a little
bit
uh are you can you hear me uh right now
yeah
yeah so tarakazi the person that
connected
okay
yeah give up
masha'allah
alhamdulillah what was really nice
talking with you
uh alhamdulillah that uh
you know
we got to meet and inshaallah you can be
somebody who um you know
sets a a good example
uh for others you know if they're in
this situation hold your composure don't
swing
and uh
inshallah
allah like you said you know is
god almighty is in charge at the end and
he's one that uh um will reward you for
your patience and whatnot because not
everybody's gonna get a chance to to do
what you did
[Laughter]
yeah all right thank you brother where
where i thought
anything else that uh you want to share
with us
no man just keep up your good work to be
honest i've been a fan of your show even
before you contacted me and i even told
my brother like ah
the dean show messaged me eddie and i
was like wow like this is this is nice
you know
hopefully if you if since you're in the
states now maybe we can get you over to
uh to our academy if you're going to be
in chicago or anywhere make sure we
reconnect inshallah anytime i'm in
chicago i will be hollering you right
that sounds good thank you brother all
right thank you
so much